you're about to watch one of the most
beautiful games I've played in recent
memory and this came in round four of
the fyra blitz tournament if you missed
the first three rounds uh I'll link a
playlist below I had three really
intense hardfought games thus far and
coming into round four I'm one and a
half out of three uh my fourth round
opponent is wfm an a shukman rated 2326
F Blitz uh which is around my rating so
uh yeah we're due to have a hard fought
game now when the round began neither of
us were actually at our board and there
was a little bit of confusion because I
had a designated board for filming and
the pairings showed uh a different Board
number so took a moment for both of us
to sit down and the Arbiter actually
started my clock and then we shake hands
and before making my move I adjust my
pieces and now the game finally begins
Pawn to D 4 and my opponent plays the
Dutch defense which is not an opening I
encounter too often but generally
against a Dutch I like to play a London
setup still and we're both blitzing out
our respective setups I play C4 castling
Knight C3 D6 and now I play this move
Pawn C5 and this is one of my favorite
pet lines against a Dutch it's
definitely not most common a lot of
players are not prepared for this uh
from on the black side the idea of C5 is
to make room for lightford Bishop also
to open up the diagonal to the black
king also put more pressure on the queen
side uh but my opponent pretty quickly
plays Pawn to C6 I play Queen to B3
check and then she plays Pawn to D5
which is somewhat of a committal move it
does block the check does strengthen
control over E4 but it loses control
over E5 I start here with Bishop to E
two just a flexible solid developing
move and she plays Knight to
E4 and now I'm trying to figure out what
exactly my plan is in the position the
most natural move is probably to Castle
kingside but I had other ideas and I
started with the move Pawn H4 which is
very thematic for this opening and the
idea is to really just keep the Rook on
H1 and support the vental break with h 5
and in many cases white can try and
orchestrate a kingside attack try and
induce some weaknesses in Black
structure so I was feeling well within
my comfort zone at this point getting
some early time Advantage opponent is
taking her
time and then she plays Knight to D7 now
when she played this move I really only
identified one purpose behind her move
is that black wants to play Knight d D
F6 and reinforce the Knight on e4
however I did miss a second purpose
behind this move which we will see very
soon so meanwhile I was trying to figure
out what to do myself uh of course H5
was my candidate move I was also
considering Knight to G5 but I do end up
playing Pawn H5 so creating tension
between the pawns on the king
side and then she starts to
think taking a bit of time
here in the moment I was expecting
Knight
df6 just to improve the Knight get kind
of a a stone wall type
setup uh but I was not anticipating the
moov she's about to play she very
confidently plays Pawn to E5 which just
creates a lot of Chaos in the center now
at first with this move it looks like
black is losing a pawn because I have
one two three pieces attacking E5 and
there's only two things defending E5
however if I take on E5 with my Pawn
then I leave my C pawn undefended and
would allow either Knight to capture on
C5 and also if I take with my knight on
E5 then there's a line takes and takes
and takes and takes and again I'm losing
my C5 Pawn in the end of that variation
so I took some time and I ended up
having uh very interesting idea which
did not revolve around addressing her
last move but rather revolved around
generating my own
counterplay and I end up playing Knight
takes D5 sacrificing my knight she
immediately recaptures I take with Queen
forcing King h8 and then I take on G6
and we wind up in a position where it
looks like I'm in full control I have
just sacrificed a kn for three pawns but
I have massive initiative along the H
file I'm threatening Maiden one with
Rook takes H7 and it looks like Black's
whole King side is crumbling here she
has no time to take my Bishop on F4 but
uh black does have a way to defend and
it turns out that this is the beginning
of what's going to be a really really
crazy sequence now she was taking time
here probably debating which Knight to
move to F6 either Knight df6 or Knight E
F6 would uh defend against the May
threat but she does play Knight E to F6
which turns out to be an annoying move
for me to meet because not only is she
defending my M threat with uh the Knight
defending H7 but she's attacking my
queen and my Bishop is still attacked on
F4 so what looked to be a position where
where I was in full control actually
looks like black is controlling
everything here my queen is hanging my
Bishop is hanging I am down a minor
piece for three pawns but here I wanted
to keep the sacrifices coming and
instead of saving my queen I play Bishop
takes E5 and this is the first moment
where I can say oh no my queen uh of
course were in a playing Hall with other
players so I did not scream that out but
uh yeah if black takes on D5 then I'll
have forc checkmate with Rook takes H7
King G8 Rook G7 King h8 Rook H7 King
goes back to G8 and then Rook h8 would
be Checkmate so my queen is untable here
and I've managed to save the bishop and
win another Pawn so everything looks to
be in really good shape for me and she
ends up playing Pawn to H6 which is
actually a very useful move in trying to
neutralize the H file and this keeps my
queen
attacked and from my perspective of
course I could move the queen I could
play a move like Queen D6 or drop the
queen back to B3 but I really wanted to
keep the pressure and keep my initiative
in the position and this is the second
Queen sacrifice Bishop to C4 and this is
another situation where black can't take
my queen if Knight takes D5 here then I
would have Rook takes H6 because Black's
Bishop would be pinned to the king the
king would be forced to G8 I would take
on D5 and Black's whole position would
crumble so for two moves in a row my
queen is attacked by Black's Knight but
the queen is untable she has to figure
out what else to do she plays Queen to
E8 which is a useful move in the
position attacking my undefended Pawn on
G6 and even though my Pawn has seemed
like a strength in the position it's
also a weakness it's overextended it's
not defended so now my queen is still
attacked my Pawn is attacked it's still
very chaotic to assess what's going on
and already at this point we have both
Fallen below a minute so things are
about to get really really
crazy I end up casting Queens sign
leaving my queen hanging for third move
in a row but black still can't take it
because of the line Rook takes H6 King
G8 and Bishop takes D5 uh not mating but
it would force black to BL with queen or
rook and I would be winning a boatload
of material in that line so black is
still under immense pressure and she's
falling very low on time falling below
seconds and then she unleashes this move
Knight to B6 which is a very clever and
resourceful move in the position because
now my queen is attacked by both Black
Knights and the only safe Square I can
move my queen is to D6 but that would
allow Knight takes C4 and then my queen
is trapped so my queen is basically
trapped in this position and she's also
Unleashed her light squired Bishop so I
don't have Queen E6 and I had to figure
out what to do with my queen being
attacked
yeah what else to do but to sacrifice it
yet again I take the Knight on B6 with
my Pawn which seemed to be the most
natural move but now she finally takes
my queen on D5 and now actually oh no my
queen my same tactical line doesn't work
as well as it did in the previous
variations because after I take on H6
King G8 Bishop takes D5 she has Bishop
to E6 and black is actually defending
but I try and keep the pressure I take
on G7 and now she has to decide which
Bishop to recapture now do note here
that I only have 5 seconds on my clock
we are playing with a 3 second increment
she takes on D5 I Blitz out Bishop to
E5 and she actually took the wrong
Bishop because now I'm still having a
manting attack threatening Rook h8
Checkmate she plays Rook C check I play
King D2 and how does black stop the
Checkmate here there's really no way she
sacrifices her Queen and now material is
in a spot where I'm the one who's up and
after Bishop G2 Rook G1 Bishop to E4 I
still have a mating attack I play Pawn
G7 after Rook C2 King D1 I am just
mating Rook h8 she tried to play King F7
but this is Checkmate and the game ends
in uh was a really really crazy tal
finish there is a lot to unpack here so
let's hop into the analysis uh the
opening I think was like very standard I
I was happy to play this pet line and um
for anyone that doesn't know what to
play against a Dutch I can very highly
recommend this variation with C5 just
because I think it's just easier to play
for white these ideas of Queen B3 and H4
and H5 going into the middle game so
let's get to the point where things got
messy uh starting with Pawn E5 and it
turns out that Knight takes D5 was the
best move in the position the first of
many sacrifices in this game sacking the
Knight and uh yeah getting um very
strong attack against Black's King and
when she played Knight ef6 this was the
best defensive try but I also responded
with the best move to just take on E5
and to show this on the board if she
does take my queen then the mate ends
like this it's somewhat of a windmill
Rook takes G7 King h8 Rook H7 King G8
and Rook h8 is Checkmate so yeah that
was the first queen sack the second
Queen sack was here when I play Bishop
to C4 and again if she takes the queen
there's takes and King G8 and takes and
the line can keep going here because
after Rook F7 I'm not immediately mating
but I would take with the pawn after
King f8 there's Bishop D6 which forces a
queen to E7 and this is what I
calculated when I played Bishop C4 uh
there's actually a really nice move here
to continue with is not to take the
queen but to play Rook
E6 uh taking advantage of the fact the
queen is pinned and if black takes a
bishop I don't take the queen I would
just mate on E8 so again she made the
right call by not taking my queen and
what happened the game um after Bishop
C4 Queen E8 was a good try and in this
moment I should have just saved my queen
I should have played Queen D6 and
understand the fact that I have four
pawns for the sacrifice Knight and even
if I allow Queen takes G6 white has uh
more than enough compensation I'd be
winning the pawn on F5 with still a
massive attack but casting Queen side
definitely kept things
and then when she played Knight to B6 I
was just in the rhythm of sacrificing my
queen every move so uh yeah I I took the
Knight and this pretty much gave away my
whole Advantage what I should have done
in this position and the best move
according to the engine was actually to
sacrifice my Rook with the move Rook
takes H6 and this is one of the only
ways to save my queen it would force
Bishop takes H6 and then I can take on
B6 and she can't take on D5 cuz the
Knight is now pinned there's no Bishop
on G7 and white is very much for Choice
here Rook H1 is coming and all my pieces
are ready to just Rampage on the king
side so it a missed opportunity for me
to uh yeah sack the rook and save my
queen but instead I sacked my queen I
took the Knight and this is where things
got really messy
because after Rook takes H6 King G8
Bishop takes D5 Bishop E6 uh we see the
point of uh why she played Knight B6
earlier was to allow the bishop to block
the check and in the moment here it felt
like I was just running out of Firepower
and when I take on G7 black is now for
choice and the move she should have
played was just to take my darksword
Bishop keeping my Rook attacked keeping
my Bishop attacked uh this position is
still far from simple because I would
have the move Rook H7 and if King takes
G6 white is winning because Rook H1 and
Rook H6 is a m threat which is very very
hard to
stop but um yeah what could have
happened was King G8 and the engine
finds a crazy move here Pawn G7 to allow
King takes H7 but then I can take on f8
and after takes Knight G5 there's still
uh some initiative it's still like
really really complex I don't think I
want to go down that rabbit hole but who
knows what would have happened there uh
I was very fortunate that she took on D5
and after Bishop E5 it turns out that
black has one defensive try that she
told me she should have played after the
game and uh we were analyzing a little
bit after the game is what if black
plays this move Rook f six at first it
looks like it's just a free rook but if
I take it then black is better after
Queen C6 hitting my king and my
undefended Bishop so if she played Rook
F6 the only way for white to keep a
winning position is to not take the Rook
just to build the battery on H file with
rook
dh1 and the prospect of Rook h8 is still
very deadly it is kind of hard to
understand because black has some checks
here but basically after King D2 my Rook
is going to be infiltrating and black is
not in good shape here so when she
played Rook C8 this allowed me to save
my king and finally get a clearly
winning position uh she did have to just
sack the queen here and the Finish was
very smooth so this is super fun game I
hope you guys enjoyed this one um if you
have questions leave them below I will
leave a link to the Lea study with this
game so if you want to analyze all the
crazy lines on your own feel free to do
so and stay tuned for more hope you
enjoy the video and I'll see you guys
soon